the Special Counsel investigation into
Russian interference in the 2016
presidential election has concluded and
Robert Muller has fully exonerated
president Trump and his entire campaign
of any collusion with the Russian
government but then just when you
thought that things couldn't get any
better the Southern District of New York
steps in not 10 minutes ago to charge
not president Trump but Democrat
celebrity lawyer Michael avenatti with
bank and wire fraud
the leftist tears have created a tsunami
get your tumblr ready and hold your
breath I'm Michael Knowles and this is
the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
I'm getting ready to go live I'm getting
ready to do my show today I think this
is the best show definitely since
Cavanaugh it's better than Cavanaugh
best show since I guess the 2016
election we didn't even have a show
during the 2016 election so this was
already gonna be the best show ever and
then just as I'm about to go live I see
breaking news the Southern District of
New York charges dot and I think Oh
because that what they did what the
Democrats did is once the Muller report
came out totally exonerates Trump then
they immediately pivot they say well the
real action is in the Southern District
of New York the Southern District of New
York is going to investigate Trump
they're going to investigate his
businesses they're going to investigate
his taxes they're gonna the Southern
District of New York is gonna take down
Trump now maybe they're gonna try to
maybe in the soy so I saw the breaking
news is that uh-oh
Southern District of New York in Deitz
Michael avenatti how is this possible
how is this reality it did I I don't
want to say anything I don't want to
even imagine anything bad happened on my
plane trip last night but did I did my
plane really land in LA or have I been
transported to the seventh heaven of
political news cycles I guess we'll have
to analyze this is this is the greatest
week for American conservatives since
the fall of the Berlin Wall I think just
everything added together the
culmination of the 2016 election will
get to all of it one second first let's
make a little money honey with untucking
you ever wonder why traditional
button-up shirts look so long and baggy
it's because they were not meant to be
worn that way untucked shirts were
specifically designed to be worn
untucked untuck 'it is the brain that
you've been looking for it's the
original untucked shirt a modern
solution to a very old problem
no tucking or tailoring required no
matter your size or shape the shirts are
the perfect untucked length I really
love them Jeremie boring got me into
untucked shirts the god-king himself
he's been wearing them for years he
loves them I would always say to him I'd
say
and that shirt looks really cool where's
it from you could say Michael do you
think I have anything in my entire
wardrobe other than untuck it shirts at
this point and it's true thing I think
he has one of every single shirt they
make he totally got me into them I love
them there they are just a fabulous
sleek modern cut I can't believe no one
ever thought to do this before them
it looks great check it I've gone to
their brick-and-mortar stores where
people are really helpful they'll fit
you out for a the right size and
obviously you can shop online try it on
in person at one of untuk it's fifty
stores or go to untuck it com2 get
started they offer free shipping and
returns on all orders in the US you can
save 20% on your first order by using my
code MKS at checkout save 20% untuck it
compro Millcote m KS here to analyze
robert Muller's findings in the russia
collusion investigation we are
privileged right now to be joined by
1970s musical legend Billy Preston Billy
what did Special Counsel Muller find
[Music]
you wanna be me
[Music]
but a bit overdue but do nothing from
nothing from nothing they found nothing
nothing at all six hundred seventy five
days twenty eight hundred subpoenas five
hundred witness interviews thirty-seven
indictments for prison sentences and at
the end of it all two years later
not one single American found to have
committed any crime any conspiracy any
collusion with the Russian government to
interfere in the 2016 presidential
election
now what not Donald Trump not Donald
Trump jr. not Jared Kushner not Paul
Manafort not Roger stone not anybody
associated with the Trump campaign not
just that not any American found to have
colluded with the Russians no collusion
this is not shocking to anybody who is
reasonable but there is a take away
before we get to Attorney General bars
letter describing the Muller report we
don't have the whole Muller report yet
we'll never get the whole Muller report
because they're actually laws preventing
them from releasing the whole thing but
maybe we'll get some version of it
everybody seems to want transparency
especially President Trump because he
has been exonerated but the first
takeaway here is people are describing
the news as shocking this is not
shocking news for the last two years
every reasonable person has known that
Donald Trump is not a Russian spy in the
yet they've built this narrative think
about how crazy that is Donald Trump the
guy who was a tabloid icon the guy who's
a real estate developer or the guy who
was a casino mogul we wear his ties the
Trump tie he was a huge star of reality
TV Donald Trump an American original
a good number of people in this country
managed to convince themselves that that
guy was secretly a Manchurian Candidate
a Russian spy who had done everything in
his life just to lead to the moment when
he would get elected president to turn
the United States of America into a
puppet government for the Kremlin a lot
of people in this country convinced
themselves of that some people I think
cynically were just pretending you know
got guys like Van Jones for instance Van
Jones big left-wing or big CNN host he
was caught on a hidden camera saying oh
that Russia thing that's a nothing
burger Russia's a nothing burger there
were some people who knew that who said
obviously Donald Trump wasn't a Russian
spy but they they pedaled it anyway
because they thought it would be
politically useful which turns out it
wasn't but a lot of people got fooled
some people I think in the media were
honest honestly wrong and corrupt some
people in among Democrats honestly
believe that ideology drives people mad
that's the only way to explain it how
could you possibly have believed that
because ideology drives people mad but
now we know President Trump fully
exonerated here even voxcom even poor
benighted voxcom said this is a massive
political win for Donald Trump what does
Attorney General Barr say so so we find
out late on Friday we find out that
Muller has filed his final report at
that time we knew no new indictments so
we said okay that's it it's over it's
done no new indictments this is done
nobody was found to have colluded with
the Russians no American but we didn't
know what was in it then Attorney
General Barr over the weekend he reads
the whole report and then he writes this
a letter to inform people it's just a
matter of public interest of what's
going on this is what he writes quote
the report further explains these losers
be highlights obviously it's a lot at
four-page letter I'll just give you the
highlights the report further explains
that a primary consideration for the
special counsels investigation was
whether any Americans including the
individuals associated with the Trump
campaign joined the Russian
conspiracies to influence the election
which would be a federal crime if they
did that that would be a federal crime
the special counsels investigation did
not find that the Trump campaign or
anyone associated with it
conspired or coordinated with Russia in
its efforts to influence the 2016 US
presidential election as the report
states now he's quoting robert muller
here quote that investigation did not
establish that members of the Trump
campaign conspired a coordinated with
the Russian government in its election
interference activities now while it
sounds a little repetitive doesn't it he
put that in there because he is quoting
the the report itself from robert muller
it did not happen and he goes on our
determination was made without regard to
and is not based on the constitutional
considerations that determine the
indictment and criminal prosecution of a
sitting president so what they've
decided here is they are not going to
indict anybody else the special counsel
is not indict anybody else that now I
suppose the Attorney General could and
they've decided they are not going to do
that and they know that what's going to
happen is they're gonna say this was
political this is because
constitutionally it's tricky to indict a
president constitutionally there are
some he said that's not because of that
he's saying we are not indict oppressor
dn't we're not indict anybody associated
because there is no reason to there's no
evidence there is there it was a Russian
interference effort we do know that
there was it was a two-pronged effort
this also apparently from the Muller
report the internet research agency was
an organization that spent some money on
social media to stir up discontent in
American politics spread some propaganda
okay the Russians have been doing this
for a long time that's the media angle
of this then the other aspect of Russian
interference is hacking the DNC which
the report says that they do okay two
sides the media angle and the political
angle the government
and those two sides of Russian
interference reflect the two sides of
the real scandal here the two sides of
the real scandal which is that the DOJ
under Barack Obama colluded and
conspired with Democrats to spy on the
Trump campaign and to try to prevent him
from being president when that didn't
work to try to overturn the presidential
election that's the political
governmental side of the scandal the
media side is that they spread these
lies and smears and baseless propaganda
for two years it's amazing to see the
the Russian interference mirror almost
exactly how the Democrats and the media
but I repeat myself reacted to the real
scandal a little bit more of bars letter
before we get to the bigger picture
first let's make a little money honey
with ring rings mission is to make
neighborhoods safer you might already
know about their smart video doorbells
and cameras that protect millions of
people everywhere
ring helps you stay connected to your
home anywhere in the world so if there's
a package delivery or a surprise visitor
you will get an alert and be able to see
hear and speak to them all from your
phone that's thanks to the HD video and
two-way audio features on ring devices
speaking of hacking and people trying to
get into your private affairs and into
your house my senior producer Jonathan
hey the other night he was woken up at
3:00 in the morning by some weirdos who
were trying to see if anybody's home so
they ring the bell he starts talking to
them from his bed he says yeah what do
you want now they didn't think anyone
was home oh uh oh nothing
that by the way Jonathan could have been
in on a beach he could have been at the
office because you can do this from
anywhere said yeah well you know you're
not gonna want to come into this house
just just letting you know so yeah okay
these kind of drug addled weirdos and
then they wander away it's really
helpful it makes you feel safer wherever
you are even if you're in your own
bedroom or if you're far away from home
as a listener you have a special offer
on a ring starter kit available right
now I love my ring it makes me feel
safer I give it to all of my friends
with a video doorbell and
motion-activated floodlight camera the
starter kit has everything you need to
be building a ring of security around
your home just go to ring.com slash
knowles kayano wles that's ring com
/ Knowles okay
now there are two questions that the
special counsel is weighing in this
letter you've got the question of did
Trump campaign collude with Russia no no
way didn't happen then there's the
question of obstruction of justice
this is the process crime this is where
they say well there was no crime but he
didn't answer investigators or he lied
to investigators so that's where the
Democrats thought they had him
most smart Democrats most reasonable
Democrats have known for a while this
Russia thing isn't going to turn up any
collusion so what they were hoping for
is okay what we can do now is where
there's no crime but we're gonna catch
him in a lie we're gonna make him
perjure himself we're gonna make him
give up some other crime that he did
we're gonna make him do that so that's
what they were trying to get him on so
what happened with obstruction the
special counsel did not find obstruction
now technically the special counsel
apparently didn't weigh in the special
counsel outlined arguments on both sides
of the difficult issues of law in fact
and then Attorney General Barr and
Deputy Attorney General rod Rosenstein
concluded that the Trump conduct does
not rise to the level of obstruction rod
Rosenstein remember they're gonna try to
paint Barr as some political actor he's
not he's got a sterling reputation he
was admired by both sides of the aisle
but rod Rosenstein has basically been
implicated by his old pals at the DOJ
and the FBI of hating Donald Trump and
trying to overturn the election rod
Rosenstein also concluded that whatever
Donald Trump did does not rise to the
level of obstruction of justice he says
quote generally speaking to obtain and
sustain an obstruction conviction the
government would need to prove beyond a
reasonable doubt that a person acting
with corrupt intent engaged in
obstructive conduct with a sufficient
nexus to a pending or contemplated
proceeding in cataloging the president's
actions many of which took place in
public view the report identifies no
actions that in
judgment constitute obstructive conduct
had a nexus to a pending or contemplated
proceeding and we're done with corrupt
intent each of which under the
department's principles of federal
prosecution guiding guiding charging
decisions would need to be proven beyond
a reasonable doubt to establish an
obstruction of justice offense this is
attorney general Barr saying dear
cynical Democrats you're going to try to
smear us and say this was just political
here is in perfect terms why we could
not charge Donald Trump with obstruction
to say nothing of the fact that there's
no crime there was no underlying crime
that's what the Special Counsel found in
no uncertain terms so what would he be
obstructing what justice would he be
obstructing a full exoneration there's
no say it loud say it proud no
conclusion nope no conclusion there is a
conclusion and the conclusion was no
collusion consider this to consider how
weird this is Donald Trump braggadocious
hyperbolic Donald Trump has had a better
record of accuracy and disinterested
statements over the past two years than
the entire mainstream media Donald
Trump's tweets have a better record of
journalistic integrity than the entire
mainstream media consider this show
I am a partisan I have a side I have
opinions I first got any notoriety
because I did a blank book called a
reasons to vote for Democrats I have a
much better record of journalistic
integrity of disinterested accurate just
the facts reporting then the entire
mainstream media that is extremely
messed up that is absurd that should not
be the case Donald Trump and I should
not have a better record of
disinterested objective reporting than
the New York Times The Washington Post
ABC CBS NBC CNN we should we should not
weep I am a political actor I have a
position I have a side that I'm
advocating for Donald Trump is the
Republican President of the United
States
he's an he's an activist he's pushing
something he's pushing an agenda he's a
much better journalist than anybody at
those outlets that is really messed at
you might be really confused by the way
you might be confused as to how this is
possible how it's possible that Donald
Trump did not collude with the Russians
and you're confused because this is what
you heard for two years
there are indictments in this
president's future that's a bombshell
the bombshell this bombshell dropped the
bombshell bombshell accusation bombshell
accusation this is evidence of
willingness to commit collusion this
BuzzFeed news report is true then we are
likely on our way to possible
impeachment proceedings if this story is
true we must begin impeachment
proceedings this is suborning perjury I
think there's no question it's an
impeachable offense and at that point we
are in high crimes that misdemeanor and
we are right this president needs to be
impeached impeachment is the remedy I
mean the president can't they always
remedy the spirit of what Trump did is
clearly Teresa dhis this is moving into
perjury false statements and even in a
potentially treatment there's outright
treason I mean there is no question I
think he's feeling the noose around his
neck the the noose is tightening and I
think they're shocked that the noose is
tightening or he feels the noose is
tightening the noose is tightening the
sound of who feeds of all those
investigations catching up with Donald
Trump must be loud in his ears he may be
the first president in quite some time
to face the real prospect of jail time
people might go to jail you're exactly
right that's their lives I think they're
all going to jail well I think they're
all going to end up together in prison
and maybe that's a gun he has no idea
that right he's going down I could play
you hours and hours and hours more of
that he's going down he's there's no
he's going to jail he's going down two
years of that 2,280 five minutes of that
just on the network's obviously news
busters you gotta love the media
Research Center they put together just
on ABC CBS and CNN not CNN
at MSNBC not any of those other stations
just the networks for the last two years
twenty two hundred eighty five minutes
they have had an average of three
minutes per night for 791 consecutive
nights an average of every 791 nights
for at least three minutes by the way
Trump polluted with Russia by the way
he's a criminal by the way he's going to
jail for that and totally wrong totally
baseless that's all in the midst of an
average of 92% negative coverage and we
only mentioned the evening networks here
this is just evening news by the way
this is not even morning shows evening
news because evening news still has a
larger audience than the morning shows
or than cable news 24 million people
combined in the audience totally wrong
totally without any basis you'll notice
I'm on the one hand celebrating I'm so
excited and on the other hand I'm
furious and that's I think how
conservatives should feel right now Bill
Kristol you know never Trump anti Trump
conservative conservative what unquote
all he's done for the last two years is
try to stop the most conservative
administration in American history he
came out he said why are the Trump errs
so upset why are they so angry first of
all they're not we're very happy were
elated I was sitting in middle seat
coach yesterday on my airplane it was
the best flight I've ever had because I
was reading the reaction and tweeting
the whole time was so fun
so great my tumblr is running over
however why are they angry I'm a little
angry too because for two years those
guys the media aided by the Democrats
aided by crooks in the FBI in the
Department of Justice tried to overturn
a presidential election based on nothing
and before they did that they tried to
prevent the guy for being president in
the first place and before they did that
they spied on the guy illegally to try
to fix the campaign so yeah I'm a little
angry you should be angry too
this is
we should celebrate and then we should
be angry and we need to get to the
bottom of this we need to get to the
bottom of how this happened don't just
leave it with how happy this is don't
just leave it with oh we can celebrate
good it turns out Trump's fine know who
launched this hoax in the first place
who with the DOJ who came up with the
steal dossier who pushed the steal
dossier who spread the steal dossier to
the whole mainstream media who was
behind that Democrats and Republicans
and so-called nonpartisan FBI and DOJ
officials I want those people run up in
front of a judge and I want them in
orange jumpsuits and I want everyone who
was Michael Flynn for instance Michael
Flynn apparently made some misleading
statements to investigators when they
set a trap for him and tried to send him
to prison I want that guy pardoned like
this minute Paul Manafort who goes look
Paul Manafort is a sort of crooked
lobbyist operative type there were about
seven million other guys like him in
Washington many of whom have done a lot
worse things than he did
that guy's in prison right now or he's
going to prison because he worked for
Donald Trump that's the real crime he's
going to prison for I want that guy
totally pardoned - and I want all the
hoaxers who started this mess in the
first place I want them in orange
jumpsuits for a very long time and then
you're gonna see a lot of Tears you're
already seeing a lot of leftist tears
over the past two nights there was oh my
gosh this one was great when my
doppelganger on MSNBC Rachel Maddow had
to break the news that the Muller report
found no collusion there's a Twitter
account
Carly bone but was suspended for posting
this clip here's the clip that she
posted of her own TV on to Twitter to do
that bill Barr stopped Muller from doing
at this point it's only bill Barr who
was speaking on Muller's behalf Robert
Muller is still at this point publicly
silent as he has been from the very
beginning although we'll have more on
that in a moment
she's crying she's been account was
suspended for that reason rachel maddow
there is by the way now denying that she
was holding back tears you can see it
you can look she's clearly emotionally
choked up and her eyes are really shiny
so I don't know maybe she put in
eyedrops right beforehand or something
but it looks as though it's pretty clear
she's holding back tears why because
these people were so personally invested
in this
they were so invested this was their
fantasy and you're watching it crashed
down around them like a doomsday cult
and the ones who can't double down or
crying but like any doomsday cult most
people are just doubling down
you know the doomsday cult goes out into
the desert they're waiting the world is
going to end at midnight and they're
waiting there for the world to end and
then what happens at midnight the world
doesn't end
so do they say oh I guess we were wrong
better luck next time
no they Double Down they say ah this is
proof that we were right we really this
is proof that we were right now it's
gonna happen in two weeks and that's
what's happening denial now among the
mainstream media here's CNN we're
hearing from the president is that I'm
100% exonerated that everything we did
under the campaign was okay and and what
I'm suggesting is that it's it may not
have been and the question is you know
Donna very quickly
impeachment are they gonna do anything
or the Nancy Pelosi and say forget it
we're not we're not there yet I think
the most important thing that we're
gonna look for next is what Jerry Nadler
just said which is he's gonna have Barr
come up they're gonna grill him on this
maybe even Muller and then they're gonna
take the next step that's oh yes oh yes
of course that's it doesn't it doesn't
really conclude it does well you know
who knows it doesn't exonerate and well
no maybe maybe maybe maybe and then some
get even bolder than this some get even
bolder than questioning impeachment
that's where we have to turn to Chuck
Todd but first before we get there and
then before we get to the total Sherri
on top of the sundae which is that the
Southern District of New York is
indicted Michael avenatti not Donald
Trump Michael avenatti
before we get to that we've got a second
bite of Facebook in YouTube go over to
Daley why
calm it is 10 bucks a month hundred
dollars for an annual membership you get
me you get the Andrew Klavan show you
get the Ben Shapiro show you have to ask
questions in the mailbag coming up on
Thursday you get to ask questions in
backstage we're doing those all the time
now you get to watch another Kingdom and
you get this now more than ever baby the
leftist tears tumblr I guess I'm
preaching to the choir because if you
don't have a leftist ears tumblr right
now if you're not currently a subscriber
you've been drowned and you're dead so
I'm sorry I'm sorry to hear that
you know I warned you many times get get
a second tumblr I know all of you are
already subscribers go get a second
tumblr because you're gonna see a lot
more waves coming go over to Daily wire
calm we'll be back with a lot more
so you've got a few different responses
from the media you've got people like
Rachel Maddow who are crying on
television at least those guys are
honest at least Rachel Maddow is well
there's no no collusion I mean some they
look so set I think was Katie tore mrs.
Luss so sad they were all just there's
no oh there's no collusion van Jones
actually the one who in his secret
candid statement said
yeah the Russia thing is a nothing
burger he said Democrats just need to be
sad about this for a while they need to
be sad that our presidents not a traitor
that the government has not been sold
out as a puppet state of Russia they
just need to be really sad they were
really hoping for it and then they can
move on
he's right they do need to move on some
there's another reaction some are even
bolder here is Chuck Todd with his new
tinfoil hat conspiracy theory and look I
think Democrats very fairly will say
well wait a minute if this doesn't
exonerate them on the obstruction
question then if you haven't resolved
obstruction how do you resolve collusion
because if you didn't get cooperation
and they obstructed in the investigation
could you necessarily get to the bottom
of the collusion question but Kate I'll
be I'll be honest with you I think that
is a hard political argument to make for
Democrats to push as hard as perhaps
some would like them to push as perhaps
some would like them to push me me but I
want you to push it's not just a hard
political argument it's a hard argument
period it's a hard legal argument it's a
hard historical argument it's a hard
factual argument because what Chuck Todd
is doing here did you catch that he said
well the special counsel concludes no
collusion on the underlying crime but
the special counsel doesn't reach any
conclusion one way or the other on
obstruction of justice but if you can't
reach a conclusion on obstruction of
justice
can you really reach a conclusion on
collusion yes you can the answer is yes
he wants he's so hoping that he can just
be clever and confusing enough to
overturn the special counsels decision
the special counsels findings yes you
can conclude even if there's an
open-ended question on obstruction you
can conclude whether or not there was
any collusion two years twenty eight
hundred subpoenas five hundred
interviews by the way President Trump
did cooperate he submitted a ton of
answers to a ton of questions by the
special counsel so that's just a
flat-out lie yes you can conclude we can
conclude definitively as does the
special counsel as does the Attorney
General as has every reasonable person
for two years Trump did not collude with
Russia you can conclude that and still
leave open the question of some
obstruction which isn't open anymore cuz
both rod Rosenstein and the Attorney
General have said there is no way that
they could possibly go after the
president for obstruction sorry dude it
just didn't work it's not just a
political no sorry it just didn't happen
he goes on it's not just play he goes on
here here is the end of his conspiracy
theory this I imagine is a good day for
the president he must be feeling
relatively good right now he is and he's
probably feeling relatively good about
his selection of bill bars as Attorney
General because this memo and the
initial understanding of what's in the
Muller report this will color what's in
the relative or before any of us
actually see it and so the the two big
determinations being one no no no
evidence of any conspiracy with Russia
and the Trump campaign but the second on
obstruction boy I tell you you know
Katie it's very confusing in here the
report did not make a decision on
obstruction
it's the Attorney General that's making
a decision on obstruction we already
know he had a very expansive view of
executive power on this front so that
isn't going to resolve the obstruction
Jim as far as congressional Democrats
are concerned in general and probably
many members of legal committee did you
hear that little little line that little
jab at the beginning well well I'm sure
that Donald Trump is really happy with
his selection of attorney general Barr
yeah real that bet he's really happy
about that right the implication being
that Barr is some crooked actor he's
some liar who is misrepresenting what's
in the Muller report oh yes
mmm he's really happy about Barr no I
think he's actually really happy about
the appointment of Robert Muller do you
know why because Robert Muller found no
evidence of collusion you hack that's
why oh he's really because here's why
he's really happy about it because the
Muller report was filed and they didn't
just release all of it to the public
right because it's illegal to do that
because you're not allowed to release
investigators information and names
about people who were investigated but
not indicted that's illegal you can't do
that and it would be very terrible if
you could do that for anybody just to
spread insinuations baselessly so he
can't do that this is yeah so you see
because they couldn't release that whole
report so the first thing that anybody's
hearing about this report is from the
Attorney General yet duh who else would
you hear it from
who else could you possibly hear it from
a leak yeah I guess you could hear it
from a leak you could hear it from some
corrupt Crone in the government or you
could make it up Chuck Todd like you've
been doing for two years that's what
you're upset about
actually the first thing we heard about
about this entire Russia collusion thing
was from you and it was lies and lies
and lies so no I don't think it's the
Trump is happy about the appointment of
Barr I think he's happy about the
appointment of Muller remember Special
Counsel Robert Muller has made two
public statements during the entire
investigation - what do you think those
statements were were they - correct the
president when he misrepresented the
investigation no it was - correct the
media it was to correct guys like Chuck
Todd who were spreading lies based on
nothing and now the truth has come out
and Chuck Todd is really upset about
that now some
admitting that the report is legitimate
so that you see that there's there's
Rachel Maddow there's the kind of first
reaction which is the other reports
legitimate man that's awful and then
there's the second reaction which is the
report no no it's not it's not true
there's nothing to see here pay no
attention to the man behind the curtain
that's the Chuck Todd reaction and then
there's this third reaction which is
kind of a combination you saw this one
on MSNBC which is that the report is
legitimate there yeah I guess there's no
collusion but it's illegitimate because
it's racist or something look if I'm in
the Trump children I'm having I'm having
a party tonight right like they won the
white privilege vergata
all right like you cannot you cannot
invest it there is not an
african-american person in this country
that could have been investigated for 22
months had their family investigated for
22 months and come away scot free if
they did that to me they popped me for
Sharron Netflix passwords of my life
[Laughter]
well I fundamentally agree that there
are more avenues of Investigation
against these people there's gonna be an
SD my investigation there's the
inaugural committee there are lots of
other ways to get at the children in
this particular case these grown adult
children who were part of what appears
to be the collusion or the conspiracy
with Russia the point people in that
these people have escaped scot-free with
no indictment and there's nothing in
that Muller report that is Vic sorry it
is unlikely there's going to be anything
in that mole report that's gonna satisfy
me in terms of why these people weren't
even brought in under oath for
questioning and there it is and there is
there is he you finally get it at the
very end he says there's nothing in the
Mulla report that will satisfy me
because Robert Muller who we've all said
for two years is this great guy and the
Muller report is totally legitimate he
didn't reach the conclusion that I
wanted so there was nothing that he
could say that will satisfy me and then
what is this other conclusion I think
what's that guy's name le mis Stahl or
something straight out of central
casting for MSNBC it's this guy le
missed all he says Robert Muller is a
racist I guess I guess that's they're
conclude
because this is what they do when the
left has no argument they just call you
a racist this is always the evidence
when a leftist calls you a racist
you know you've won the argument it's
just these are either racist yeah I
can't account for my lies and smears and
deceptions and propaganda over the last
two years so he's a racist yeah I that
one's gonna ask the one I think uh-huh
yeah we're gonna stick with he's a
racist that's the one here is when
they're not smearing here is what they
do the last thing that the left can do
you've got all the different the sadness
the tears the pay no attention to the
man behind the curtain the yeah I guess
it's true but it's racist the last thing
that they can do this is really the most
dishonest of all of them is to Gaslight
to say it's not real that's not what
Muller's saying that's not no no no no
la la la here's Maxine Waters also on
Joe Reed show and you have Donald
Trump's supporters including his former
UN Ambassador nikki Haley out there
tweeting and saying essentially
presuming that the president has been
exonerated by the report and in Nikki
Haley's case saying that it's been
completed and everyone should just move
on it's it's it's a curious position to
take since we don't know what's in the
report but do you see colleagues on the
other side of the aisle sort of
declaring this whole thing at an end and
wanting no further inquiry I know that
the house has something like 80
subpoenas still out absolutely well I
want to tell you that this president has
a way of trying to get into people's
heads and indoctrinate them he's been
saying no collusion no collusion no
collusion over and over again for a long
time now and he's going to try and
conclude that there this report is
proving that there's no collusion and
you have a lot of his sycophants who
will you know take the nod from him and
they'll say the same thing but we cannot
allow them to get away with this we
cannot allow them to accurately and
precisely read verbatim the Muller
report that's what she's saying it's not
Trump who saying that it's Robert
it's the special counsel and then it's
the Attorney General and then it's the
president because that's the truth
so this is mostly a media scandal I
focus mostly on the media because they
are the real dirtbags in all of this and
they have no credibility and you should
never if they if you if you find a
mainstream media reporter in a bar and
you say hey what are you drinking he saw
I'm drinking a Bud Light don't believe
him he's probably lying you can't even
believe them on that that is how much
they have totally destroyed their
credibility over the last two years
because of this it's mostly a media
scandal this hoax is not just the great
one of the greatest political scandals
in US history it is the greatest single
greatest media scandal in US history but
it's also a political scandal it's not
just the MSM it's the politicians who
hyped this then we expect them to do
this we expect the cynical politicians
to do this doesn't mean we should let
them off the hook here is House
Judiciary Chairman Jerry Nadler trying
to hold a press conference today and the
the wonderful Patriot standing out there
won't let him off the hook for his lies
executive privilege must be asserted by
the president personally at my boot and
and as the Nixon case in front of the
Supreme Court which was decided 9 to
nothing pointed a pointed out executive
privilege cannot be used to shield or
hide wrongdoing you're a bunch of losers
that's what he said lose again Nadler
you're a bunch of you're a bunch of
losers and up and that's true that is
obviously true they lost we won
they lost reality one fantasy lost
cynical fantasy but more than that
they're a bunch of sore losers everybody
loses sometimes you lose you act like a
gentleman and you move on but they
didn't do that they tried to overturn an
election and they're still trying to do
it here's bait O'Rourke living in bait
Oh Fantasyland you have my opinion
beyond the shadow of a doubt sought to
however ham had colluded with the
Russian a foreign power to undermine oh
he's just awful
he is just since shivers up my spine how
creepy this guy is we will we in my
opinion this is another example of
people don't know what the word opinion
means they think it just can be a
subjective preference like I like
chocolate ice cream you like vanilla ice
cream that's my opinion no no that's a
preference preferences are subjective
opinions or statements of fact I think
it's my opinion that the sky is blue
it's my opinion that two plus two equals
four that's my opinion you can have true
opinions or false opinions so beta or
work says what's my opinion that Donald
Trump colluded with a foreign power okay
that's your opinion but it's wrong
that's an incorrect opinion don't take
my word for it take Bob Muller's opinion
for it bata or works opinions not worth
very much if that's his opinion because
that opinions wrong his judgment isn't
worth very much but we already knew that
this underlines what I've been saying
about the Democrat primary for weeks now
it is divorced from reality
it's like play-acting that's what it is
they are play-acting you know in a
fantasy universe
actors good actors in good plays and
movies live truthfully in imaginary
circumstances so they take the
circumstances around them and they react
truthfully to them bad actors just say
rehearsed lines automatically regardless
of circumstances they say acting good
acting is reacting this guy's not
reacting
he's just say his programmed line that
he's been saying all-time trump colluded
with russia Trump know the circumstances
have changed
they now tell you beyond a shadow of a
doubt it didn't happen but he keeps
playing the fantasy and the fantasy came
crashing down and this is the central
conservative consolation not just here
not just with regard to Russia or Donald
Trump or any of that broadly speaking
when you think about everything
conservatives are up against cynical
identity politics pandering mob rule the
rousing of passions of among the mob all
of the things that we're up against as
conservatives the one consolation we
have in the long run is that eventually
reality reasserts itself and reality has
reasserted itself here that's what has
happened reality has fine took two years
took 2,800 subpoenas it took an average
of three minutes a night for 791 days on
the media took so long but reality has
reasserted itself and so we are gonna
celebrate and we're gonna dance and
we're gonna play Billy Preston say
nothing from nothing leaves nothing in
the Muller report and then tomorrow we
should be furious and we should take
every bit of energy every bit of focus
that the Dever the the Democrats and the
media have had for two years pursuing
fantasy smearing spreading lies we
should take all of that focus and pursue
the truth and we should find out who
started this hoax we should find out who
funded this hoax we should find out
which crooks in the government used this
hoax as an excuse to spy on the Trump
campaign and who pushed it in the media
and who pushed it in the government and
who pushed it among the debt we should
find them we should align them up before
a judge
and we should put them in orange
jumpsuits that's what's next investigate
the dossier there the Democrats are not
going to let up they're gonna keep these
investigations going and we should fight
their fantasy with reality we have the
upper hand right now we are on the
higher ground we should use it a
president Trump is it a real turning
point in his presidency he can either
take the win and move on as some want
him to do or he can fight and we know
he's a fighter he thought these guys
tooth and nail for two years and he won
because reality was on his side and I
can't wait for the next two years that's
our show I'm gonna be sitting in for
Ben's radio show today so the back two
hours of that I'll be in for obviously
we could keep talking about this for two
more hours and we're gonna do that I
will have Professor Alan Dershowitz and
former independent counsel Ken Starr
will be joining us to talk about the
legal and political ramifications check
it out in the meantime and otherwise
I'll see you tomorrow I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
the Michael gold show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy Moore senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
clever and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jessa
all Vera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright day Lee
Weyer 2019 hey guys over on the Matt
Walsh show today of course we've got the
molar report coming out and it says that
there's no evidence of collusion well
the left is in mourning about that what
does it say that they're upset think
about what they're upset about they're
upset that the president didn't collude
with Russia shouldn't shouldn't they be
happy about that
also what is it what does it say about
the media that they spent two years
pushing this hoax well nothing good on
both counts we'll talk more about that
also Kamala Harris says that all
teachers need a raise but is that true
we'll get into the specifics there today
as well over on the Matt Walsh show